Desde telescopios hasta el Gran Colisionador de Hadrones,
cada nueva herramienta científica reinventa las preguntas
que nosotros, como científicos
y mentes curiosas, podemos hacer con fundamento.
La computación de alto rendimiento, o HPC,
se unió a esa lista de élite en los años sesenta. Hoy,
las computadoras cuánticas están llamando a esa misma puerta.
Bienvenido. Mi nombre es conducive to coffee
y soy ingeniero de software aquí en IBM Quantum.
En este curso, nuestro objetivo es enseñar a estudiantes
y profesionales cómo la computación cuántica pronto
trabajará junto con las infraestructuras de HPC
para ofrecer una capacidad de cómputo
que no tienes hoy. Aprenderás cómo las computadoras cuánticas
y las clásicas se comunican e intercambian datos,
cómo escribir programas que aprovechen ambos tipos de hardware
y cómo esta integración abre nuevas aplicaciones que hoy no podemos resolver.
Ganarás experiencia práctica con hardware cuántico real
y clusters clásicos de computación de alto rendimiento,
ejecutando trabajos cuánticos junto a cargas de trabajo tradicionales de HPC,
y aprenderás a interpretar resultados con confianza
e identificar dónde la aceleración cuántica
puede realmente ayudar en los cálculos
y dónde no. Sobre todo, entenderás
hacia dónde se dirige el futuro de las computadoras
y el mapa del camino que nos llevará allí. Creemos
que este curso es tanto importante
como oportuno, y creemos
que combinar estas tecnologías será esencial
para lograr una ventaja computacional.
Esto podría tener impactos de amplio alcance en industrias
como la química, posiblemente permitiendo
el diseño más rápido de fármacos e investigación de materiales,
en finanzas
para modelos de riesgo más inteligentes
y detección de fraude, en inteligencia artificial y aprendizaje automático
para la optimización de modelos. En este curso
nos adentraremos en profundidad en los recursos computacionales,
modelos de programación y algoritmos cuánticos.
Así que bienvenido y prepárate,
hay mucho de qué hablar.